hey what's up guys thanks for tuning in
to are you garbage please make sure you
go subscribe to the youtube channel that
way you get the videos
as they come out yeah do it
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is
are you garbage the show we sit down
with your favorite comedians and find
out if they grow up classy
or if they're absolute trash i'm your
host dave foley coming at you on a
beautiful day
down here in the basement aunt tutti's
place she's up there taking a nap so
let's try to keep her down
she had a [ __ ] tough night last night
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me
he's the ceo of ru garbage he's my best
pal in the whole world
give it up for kevin james ryan
everybody
thanks everybody thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes full video available
on youtube those numbers are through the
[ __ ] roof thank you very much
also you know help us pay the bills
patreon.com are you garbage you can get
bonus
uh episodes of ayg you'll you get hard
feelings with just me and foley
love that money and also top tier we
play uh we do a live stream where we
play ayg with you guys you ask us
questions we ask you questions it's a
good [ __ ] time get involved baby yes
sir i love you buddy
cool and how about a nice shout out to
our producer extraordinaire
the pride of the chicago comedy scene we
all know him as t-bone
toby mcmullen everybody what up we got a
great show
we got a hat one coming at you hot pod
coming at you because gang we got a
little [ __ ] star
power in this dump today not the usual
bozos
you see running through here all right
this gentleman
is an incredibly funny incredibly
successful stand-up comedian podcaster
and actor
you have seen him but he comes out of
this [ __ ] rap sheet right here this
is like an episode of [ __ ] law order
special victims unit we got benders we
got guy code girl code the late show
with david letterman
got that [ __ ] hippie you got in the
chair these days
you got the challenge you have gotham
comedy live guy court don rickles one
night only
seth meyers steve harvey his own comedy
central half hour
the nightly show with larry wilmore
comedy knockout
what's your [ __ ] deal ultimate
beastmaster
stupid questions with christa stefano
this week at the comedy celly tiger
belly
and most recently colin quinn and
friends he's got his own special out
size 38 waist
he has a brand new podcast out called
hey babe
and of course he is one half of the
history hyenas
he's a young good-looking kid with a
[ __ ] great jawline
gotta have a nice piece on him cause
he's a [ __ ] big guy
give it the [ __ ] up for chrissy chaos
chris the stefano everybody thank you so
much that was the
one of the best intros i've ever had um
the only thing i worry about is because
this is i would think
one of the first podcasts we've done in
biden's america
yeah and uh it's three white guys i
don't know if it's legal or illegal
toby's trans that's okay so
that's why he's off camera what's his
name again toby mcmullen
it's like a made-up [ __ ] name for
like i'd be like a cop
in a [ __ ] novel i'm gonna need your
badge mcmullen if somebody said what's
your name
if i was a police officer and i pulled
you over and you and i was like name you
were like toby mcmullen
like what's your real [ __ ] name her
name's not toby mcmullen
have you given a fake name to a cop um
have i given a fake name to a cop
no i've never i'm not i'm the kind of
guy i have
especially with the police even though
like i know i like look like a cop and
could probably get out of things i
i have a certain degree of anxiety
around cops because when i was 16
i was thrown up i had a baton suck up my
ass no
i was i was like rambo never made a
movie about me
yeah i know i was thrown up against the
wall
uh like i was just walking home and i
was thrown up against the wall
handcuffed
wow and then it was just like timing i'm
throwing up against the wall handcuffs
sitting down they had me sitting down on
like
a fire hydrant stool thing and i fit a
description it wasn't me i was i was
coming home from basketball practice and
my mother was walking by
from work with groceries i was like
crazy it starts hitting them with their
purse
christopher what are you doing and then
christopher you keep your [ __ ] mouth
shut all right yeah and then and then i
just was like i didn't do anything mom
like i'm innocent
no way and then my mother my mother said
this
again was 16 so i guess it was 2000 year
2000 my mother was like
if you don't have like she i didn't know
like my mom's just like a regular woman
like
doesn't know anything about the law like
never got in trouble nothing
she walked with the officer and she was
like you need to tell me the charges on
my son right now or i'm getting my
lawyer down here immediately i've never
had my mom at first
in my life i've never had my mom cursed
in my life and she was like you [ __ ]
do it and you do it now
tell me the charges and then they were
like do we have anything on this kid
they're like no we didn't find anything
and then they unhooked me and then it
was just like one of those things where
i was like
since then i like i never give fake
names to the police i've had like this
thing with the cops where i'm like you
know and it's interesting too because
there's been
times where i've i've gotten pulled over
and done that thing like in liar lyra
i'm like you know i have
there's weed in the back i have unpaid
parking tickets
don't rob a bank with this dude yeah the
jewels are in the trunk
yeah everyone's like you know cause like
the stefano and the stories i tell about
my dad it's like you know i'll rat
immediately yeah yeah
i just want to point out too i was going
to ask you if you think you're garbage
but when you use the term
unhooked yeah that's that's pretty it's
pretty well look dude i'm from a place
called
like ridgewood queens which is just a
[ __ ] garbage place it's
it's a beautiful place and i'm proud of
it but it's one of those things where
it's like you know
let's just say you know a few of my a
few let's just say
a few of the people i grew up with were
in washington dc last week
a lot of pipefitters in original yeah
the fbi was had
had a presence in ridgewood over the
past couple of weeks so it's just what
it is and you know
i'm i'm proud to be from that hood but i
kind of got out i got my mother's still
there so i'm out and in at the same
time but yeah i come from like you know
the the lower not lower class but like
you know working class we're like white
you know we're [ __ ] it was like a
it's like a neighborhood like a very
blue collar
we got a neighborhood you know what i
mean we got you we want to heal the
i want to hear the whole story so start
starts in the beginning you were born
and raised in
ridgewood ridgewood bushwick area so
that really i was born in an area now
that's like very gentrified a lot of you
know comedian peers live there now
a lot of like yoga stuff and all muffin
shops and [ __ ] but like when i was
growing like there's a
pizzeria called roberta's that's like a
famous pizzeria in bushwick
and everybody goes it's like a hipster
trendy spot and i swear to god it's on
flushing avenue
in like 1997 that's where i saw my first
dead body
there was a homeless guy all right his
body was laying there on fire
so we just missed we had just missed
pizza must be good huh
and dude everybody so much for the coal
oven everybody's parents when i was kid
everybody's parents it didn't matter
what [ __ ] race religion whatever you
are
everybody's parents like do not pass
flushing avenue do not go
past flushing avenue you can't do it it
gets bad down there and then you know
the one time we do it or the first time
he did it we saw a homeless guy
we assumed to be homeless just on fire
laying in the middle of the street
and then literally at that intersection
is where the roberta's pizza
place is now which is like a vegan
[ __ ] trendy place where i'm like
and look it's good for us it's kind of
like texas oil money where like
my mother owns this yeah a bunch of
idiots not gonna have a lot of money
yeah my mother
my mother owns the same dilapidated
[ __ ] house that i grew up in hasn't
changed anything since 1984.
and it's like she could sell it probably
for millions of dollars right now to
some [ __ ]
idiot who like wants to live near the l
train i'm like [ __ ] if you want to
pay 10 grand for his
rat filled studio do it like whatever
your [ __ ] dream is
i mean but i know that this neighborhood
we're kind of sitting there like why do
people want to live here
in ridgewood bushwick but it's a new hot
spot so you know
it's good investment for us i guess same
thing happened in philly all my
all my uncles lived in this town called
fish town and then that was like the
brooklyn
philly punch line is right yeah yeah
right there and like they all just like
cashed out and like bought like [ __ ]
houses down in like
wildwood new jersey yeah yeah i mean
look because it's like look dude you
know if you want to [ __ ] if these
hipsters want to come in here and you
know
whatever whatever they want to do dude
you want to go to you know 12 to
12 people in one bedroom fine dude it's
15 g's a month
but you can walk to the l train and
there's diversity which i it's very
important yale yeah so here it is baby
you know the the border of of brooklyn
queens is always an interesting thing
and i thought
i thought you were a bay ridge guy well
bay ridge is where i live now where
janice giannis used to live it's where
our studio is for the
history of union so we did a lot of bay
ridge stuff but i i went to school at st
joseph's which was in downtown brooklyn
and a lot of those kids were from bay
ridge so i
started going and hanging out in bay
ridge on third avenue since i've been
like 20 years old
is that a hump from from bridgewood
what did you just say is that a hump
yeah what the [ __ ] is that is that
philly suffers that garbage [ __ ] he's
just trash okay yeah yeah i mean it's
probably trashy philly if we want to get
into it because our hump is like a
height
because i know that there's you know
there's philly things and and all that
stuff but it's like when you say a hump
it's like i gotta know
like that's not everybody in philly
right
just his dirtball family no which is
great i love it yeah but um it's yeah
bay ridge bay ridge
is that he literally took offense to you
saying that i love it he was like hold
on what'd you say what
no because it's like no i i'm not
offended but i'm just saying what a nice
conversation
what the [ __ ] yeah but but bay ridge is
bay ridge is at the
last neighborhood in brooklyn so it's
it's really one of those things like
where even the prices of houses are high
there because that neighborhood
you know it could be corrupt at times so
it's like they want to keep people out
they want to keep the price high i'll
tell you this
in 2016 when trump got elected
i i went out where every other neighbor
i'll never forget i
uh when he got elected you know i was in
the west village and then i went to go
visit my mom
in bushwick and it was like somber it
felt like 9 11. like it genuinely
because i was in new york on 911 it felt
like
9 11. bay ridge was a [ __ ] party
how about this i went to a bakery i went
to a bakery on third avenue they were
handing out
free black and white cookies because
trump won they were just giving
everybody a free black and white
new york times it's a great day the
chocolate icing scraped off
[ __ ] ninos nino's uh nino's pizzeria
on third avenue
a couple of halloweens ago i was taking
my daughter trick-or-treating in bay
ridge
they gave my everybody else giving candy
nino's gave put a cup of marinara sauce
[Laughter]
yeah but they're great as you know it's
like they're great people like they're
loyal people
i get it how like if you're not from new
york
and you have come here like let's say
you know the people you know to pursue
comedy and you're like woke and dope
which is fine whatever but like you
covered in bay ridge it's just like it's
a different world just understand that
people don't think like you yeah
you know they're not bad people but it's
like they're they just they
they'll give you the shirt off their
back but it's like just know like you
know they don't necessarily love
aoc yeah you guys don't see eye to eye
on it yeah which is which i think is
which for me is like that's fine like i
think there should be a bay ridge and
there should be a williamsburg
brooklyn polar opposites that's what the
beauty of america is but sometimes i
feel like
well now you can't even have like a
discourse you can't even have a
disagreement it's like
one side it has to be my way of the
highway which is just a huge problem
no i totally agree yeah for sure yeah
what's the uh
your mom and dad they were were they
married no yeah you got a story yeah
tell us the story from jump so my father
okay so here's the thing
my mother highly educated articulate
woman graduated from columbia university
ivy league
school that [ __ ] doesn't happen out of
ridgewood worked in the town stock
worked in the towers
second she worked for second tower that
was hit she worked for an insurance
company called
uh i'm sorry a bank called bank of nova
scotia nice so
so i think that was the company at the
time yeah i'm pretty sure that was still
the name
of the company when she was on 9 11. but
so she worked in the second tower that
was hit right but where they met
was and she was fine and it was all good
but but but where where they met was
it's so ridiculous too because on this
is just like [ __ ]
you know again brooklyn ridgewood [ __ ]
my mom
on 911 i don't know what's happening to
my mom i'm a hysterical crying got into
a huge fight
broke a chair over a kid's head it was
like a whole [ __ ] thing yeah
it's one of the best things ever so that
yeah so basically that in a nutshell is
just i broke a chair over kid's head
because i was crying
because i thought my mom was dead i
[ __ ] put this kid in almost a coma
because i just smashed his kid head i
got thrown out of the school my father
had to come down
and start negotiating with the principal
basically threatened the principal's
life
told him that if he doesn't put me back
into school because my father is was a
career criminal
he's a neighborhood guy he's a neighbor
guy and he was like look he told the the
principal straight up he said look
he's and this is why like i knew my dad
was like a real guy and even gave me the
chills
he was like i'll [ __ ] he goes either
you put my son back in school
he said i'm going to come over there and
break both your legs because here's the
thing
he said he said i know you're going to
think that i wrote that line that he
said i know you're going to think that i
heard that line in a movie he's like but
i'm one of the guys they write the
movies about
he goes i'd rather go to prison and he
said to him he's good
i'd rather go back to prison and be with
my friends then you throw him out and me
have to listen to his mother's [ __ ]
mouth for the rest of my life
dude i've watched the clip like i don't
[ __ ] love it but he said to me he
said he said it's an easy choice for me
but what choice are you gonna make and
then he told me chris he locked the door
and then and then i was like oh [ __ ] so
my dad's like a real
dude like that and then and then my mom
by by the way
she's new yorker she's from new york
everybody my whole family is new york
everybody's from new york so what did
they mean
how did this all happen it was crazy it
was crazy but real quick it's just my
mom
after 9 11 at when 9 11 the day of i
didn't know where she was when i finally
get home like i thought like she was
like a ghost i thought like she was dead
or whatever she was there bleeding from
her legs
and i'm like oh my god i like was gonna
in that moment i was like gonna join the
marines like they [ __ ]
like you're doing stuff like that like
you know but she was like she's like
i'm like what happened oh my god like is
it somebody else's blood she's like no
no no i fell off the bus in brooklyn
and i was like how do you escape 911 and
then you fall off the q55
what the [ __ ] but but my father was
career criminal
um my mother ivy league graduate they
met at a walkathon
my mother was walking in the walkathon
raising money for whatever
great cause coming out is just like a
great genuinely like great tv mom person
okay and my father was doing community
service on the side of the walk-a-thon
so he was in like a full orange jumpsuit
picking up garbage
flirting with women walking through this
hey blondie where you going yeah
my mother says that he squeezed her she
feels a squeeze and he was squeezing her
butt
once with the guards pick up laughing
and she was such an artist
she was such like an articulate well to
do goody two shoes woman she was like
you know i wanted to
have a fling with a bad boy and you're
the result
wow so i have this interesting thing
where it's like why i i don't have
interesting but it's just this
dichotomy about me where it's like my
mother's highly educated
so i got you know pushed in school got
all the way through graduate school got
a doctorate degree in physical therapy
on my mom's side and then on my father's
side
it's like i was taught at 12 13 years
old like i know how to hotwire a car
yeah you know what i mean so it's like
and and then he never taught me that
because he was actively i wasn't
involved in any of his crimes nothing
like that like they would do that like
for fun and be like my dad thought that
was important to know but my dad thought
it was important to like
know how to like shoot a gun but it's
like he doesn't have a gun license
but there was guns in the house you're
like leo from the departed yeah so it's
like walks in both worlds baby
giannis always makes fun he always says
um um what's what's a good will hunting
he's like oh it's like
you're from this neighborhood but it's
like you know like you're [ __ ] have
this like
education whatever but that's all my mom
that's all my mother is like
she was like you're going to be highly
you're going to be as educated a
chiropractor
or a physical therapist physical
therapist you have a doctorate doctor
degree in physical therapy i haven't
practiced
so you're doctor to stefano i mean
technically yeah but i don't ever do
that or call i
do it because it's like so what am i
going to do [ __ ] massage you it's
like i'm not
i'm locked dude but i do have a clinical
doctorate i can like teach in
universities and stuff like that but i
haven't practiced since 2013 2014 but
with the pandemic
my license had expired with the pandemic
governor cuomo from new york just
reinstated every health professional's
license
full active license which is crazy it's
like i can legally just do this again i
have no idea what i'm doing
i forgot everything but i could walk in
and be like yeah dude i [ __ ] got
it it's like i have no business
having my license act i genuine first of
all when i stopped practicing was a
pediatric physical therapist working
with like mentally and physically
handicapped kids
so it's like to go from that to like try
to like work on an adult because when
the quarantine
when kovid was getting like really crazy
and the quarantine was getting really
nuts it was like
you know [ __ ] like i got a kid i got
another kid on the way i'm like just
bought a house i'm like am i gonna have
to start doing physical therapy again
and then i try to like just work on um
my girl my
girlfriend who like and was like let me
just try out and i literally one of the
first techniques i tried to do
i pulled her hamstring and she for three
weeks
couldn't exercise like literally the
first thing like she was crying on the
floor no refunds
and i was like i'm sorry i'm used to
working with smaller hands
that's crazy wait okay so without going
into too much detail if you can or not
like
describe your dad like what what are we
talking about here no my dad
it's one of those things where it's like
people like i i never really witnessed
him do anything i'm not going to sit
here and be like oh
[ __ ] you know who my vocal father is i
always no like when people start saying
that it's like oh it's probably because
your
family is nothing that's why [ __ ]
because if you actually were a part of
it you'd be like i'm not necessarily
proud of this
i talk about comedy and i embellish
details and all that
but you know he was one of those guys
like he just [ __ ] is a wild guy like
but
the thing is with my dad it was always
like right intention wrong move nobody
in my opinion like loves me more than my
dad so it's like sometimes i would tell
these stories and people back oh that's
sad or like a therapist like no what are
you talking like
my dad is like the greatest guy like he
would take me to the otb racetrack and
then he take me to aqueduct
racetrack and watch the horses which
you'd be like oh my god you shouldn't do
that because we're like
i'm like he's like a degenerate gambler
but like hey kid bigger number one dude
i like had the best time it was like
living like in a bronx still like they
bought me pretzels i'd drink mountain
dews and it would be the whole thing
like he would take me down
he would buy me take me to aquaduck
racetrack for the day and then would be
the same thing when we got to my corner
he would be like remember
what did we tell your mother where were
we and i was like at the zoo
tell me to tell my really so he took me
to the bronx zoo and i
like that's what you know and i thought
but we were watching the horses
gang we got big news here at the ru
garbage studios here at aunt duties
ru garbage is joining the stereo app
and we could not be more excited stereo
is a free live broadcast social platform
that enables people to have real
conversations in real time
so uncle hank and kippy are going to be
doing some special
triple bonus shows for you on the stereo
app
okay and if you don't know what stereo
is stereo is an application
that allows podcast creators to build a
more intimate relationship with their
fan base
okay it's a very engaging product you
can record a message you can send it in
we're going to be doing live shows it's
going to be absolutely fantastic we love
it because you can do it from anywhere
it's like having a little podcast studio
right in your hand are you garbage could
not be more excited to offer our
listeners a new way to interact with us
so join us thursday night january 28th
at 9 00 p.m
live on the stereo app we're going to be
doing our first show you can download
the free stereo app and you can select
ru garbage so you can connect with us
wherever you live it doesn't matter
where you are
we're going to be right there like we're
all in the same room it's going to be
fantastic
just do me a favor stay tuned to the end
of the episode
for more details and if you want to
hurry up and get started
you can go to stereo.com are you garbage
get yourself signed up it's going to be
absolutely fantastic thursday january
28th
9 p.m are you garbage on stereo app
it's going to be great hang on a second
there gang it's your old pal
uncle hank i want to take a quick minute
and talk to you about honey
listen we all shop online we know this
okay and we've all gotten to the
checkout
and we've seen that promo code field
just staring at us like we're a bunch of
idiots
because we got nothing well now honey
can make that a thing of the past
honey is the free browser extension that
scours the internet for promo codes
and applies the best ones to your cart
okay honey supports over 30 000 stores
online
they range from anything from gaming
products to popular fashion brands food
delivery
i'm gonna tell you right now i got it i
installed it it's free
uncle hank got a pizza for six bucks
last night
six bucks don't tell kippy because i'm
not supposed to be eating pizza
but with honey you got to make a move on
it it's unbelievable
listen gang i want to be clear here
honey has found it's over
17 million members okay
they found them two billion dollars in
savings that's b
billion not million billion so let's get
a little call to action here all right
i'm putting it on you the garbagio army
to go out there and support honey
okay if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out on free
savings
okay it's literally free it installs in
a few seconds
and by getting it you're doing yourself
a solid
and you're supporting this podcast
you're supporting the people
that support this podcast so listen up
get honey for free
you want to go to joinhoney.com garbage
that's jointhoney.com garbage and start
saving today
now let's get back to the show and then
and then the otb racetrack in my
neighborhood so in ridgewood when i grew
up if you went to the left
there was the otb racetrack if you went
to the right you would get to you could
if you went it was basically like a fork
in the road the church was at the top of
of the hill so if you went to the right
you get to the church if you went to the
left you could get to the church but to
the left the otb racetrack when my
father was taking me which my mother
told me do not take him in there
told degenerate gamblers and losers
which he would take me there all the
time
he would be like you know when you go to
church with your mother and i'm not here
you always go to the right you never go
to the left because he knew if i walked
past the otp racetrack
all these people scotty karate johnny
johnny the screw
hey there he is yeah johnny the screw
scotty cried i was like their lucky
children yeah
i would always pick like good horses
they would rub my head and you know
[ __ ] johnny the screw gave me a sip
of beer when i was eight
you know like so it's like awesome stuff
and it's like and it's like and i
remember one time like i forgot and like
i walked past
the otb racetrack at the otb place and
my [ __ ] they were like yo chris hey
what's up whatever my mother was like do
you know these guys
and i was like no they're in my class
and i was like and i was like no
and i never said anything about it i
said i don't know how they know me
whatever mine was like well if they know
you you're a little boy like what's
going on there she knew you were lying
well she knew but i never said anything
and then
for you and it was crazy and then my
mother called my father she's like we
all need to have a talk
about what's been going on with with our
son you mean because they were
my parents were divorced they got
divorced immediately so they did get
married
um i think they got married but they
were divorced i mean i me i i pretty
sure my mother told me she was
pregnant with me serving divorce papers
so so i think they may have gotten
married quickly because like catholic
guilt [ __ ] whatever
but divorce immediately but but um you
know my father i'll never forget like
we're
having uh having uh you know the meeting
my dad i'm sitting there whatever and my
dad comes up
the stairs and my mom is like you know
we really need to speak about
your son's behavior and what's been
going on and and he's been at the
racetrack and doing these things and you
would think like the father would be
like you know like chris you whatever
like
you know i shouldn't have taken you
there and my dad said to my mom and he
goes i got nothing to say to you lady
because my son's not a rat and that's a
good thing that's what he said and then
she was i remember my mother like who
never does this i'll never forget she
went into the fridge
and cracked open to sam adams and just
drank it alone at the kitchen table was
like
i have now i'll never forget she was
like i have now aligned myself
with a [ __ ] man and i'm telling you
until i my whole
as i got older and like needed less and
less responsibility and got my own
independence or whatever it became
you know less and less of a problem but
for most of my life my parents didn't
talk
you know my once i got old enough my mom
and dad were like okay we created you
like
we both love you independently but like
i don't care what she's doing she
doesn't care what i'm doing
not to like better off better off and
how often would he see you
my dad my dad's one of those guys never
missed a basketball uh game of mine my
very first show i ever did in 2010 at
the [ __ ] maui taco my dad was in the
front row
laughing at all these jokes that were
[ __ ] potentially incriminating him
and his
because you friends i've been doing this
ten years now i didn't have at that time
you know you develop a bit of a skill
set where it's like i could tell a story
and embellish the right details but also
make it sound believable protect the
innocent back then i was just naming
names
because i just like i just want to get
laughs
it was just like whatever and uh but he
never missed anything and my mother
didn't either my mother both great
individual parents but not until i had
my daughter five years ago
were they like now we're gonna come
together and now it's like they actually
they actually like get along because
it's like my dad's been remarried to my
stepmom who's awesome for 30 years
my mom has her [ __ ] cats and [ __ ]
like it's just everybody's happy yeah
you know everybody loves my daughter
like my daughter has now become like the
centerpiece
of the family so that's what's like
beautiful about having a child i know
this is [ __ ] gay and my dad would be
watching this like
just sucked a microphone but it's like
it is beautiful children where it's like
she just
you know my parents didn't talk at all
and now it's like just this child is
like
[ __ ] boom and i'm having a second
child due date july really due date july
4th the kid's a patriot and if that
if that baby comes out on july 4th
there's one name and one name only
donald trump donnie d
i don't know i like it boy or girl the
kid's name's donald
congratulations yeah that's awesome no
it's what it is it's quarantine stuff me
and my
kid's mom actually split up for a little
me and my girl split up for a little
while
and then quarantine kind of brought us
back together
little by little and then it's just one
slips past the goalie it's what it is
she's a beautiful like sexy puerto rican
girl and it's like it's just one
that's the thing it's like even my
father that kid's got a sweet dude
because when we first met do it it's so
funny too because when i got her
when i get it you don't got to sell us
yeah i'm not puerto rican chicks dude
i'm in
but my dad because it's funny like i
told my mom who like you know cause
when i first had you know my daughter
delilah she
we i didn't know her mom it was the
second date and her mom got pregnant we
were just like oh [ __ ] so i barely even
know this one we're about to have a baby
whatever whatever i tell my mom she
flips out and then i go to my father and
stepmother and i'm like
you know like like um i i did this i'm
you know i'm looking forward to it i i
don't need you guys to yell at me i just
need your support but like
you were excited i was excited i was
like there was never a doubt in your
mind oh my she hit you up she says hey
you're pregnant i'm like you know what
like [ __ ] fine i i got my career
going i got my education
sure beautiful girl i know at the very
least we'll make a hopefully you know
she's such a beautiful girl we have a
beautiful
daughter and if things don't work out
they don't work out whatever like life
is too short to get caught up on that
similar to your parents situation
exactly i was like if they make it work
i can make it work and it's like
you know i'm telling them that and my
stepmother's just think you know like
yelling you know she's an older woman
she's like i can't believe you would do
this do the career or whatever and then
my dad's like
all right it happens he goes let me see
a picture let me see a picture
and then so i show it and my dad looks
at my son and goes he goes d
i would have done the same he goes are
you kidding me chris and then in front
of his wife by somebody goes does she
have a hot mom
and then and then and then my stepmom's
like yeah what what is she going to do
with you [ __ ] he goes he goes i'm
going to trade you in for 22 years she
goes i'd like to see you try your fat
[ __ ]
she was like that's what yeah she's like
i'm sure that's what her hot spanish mom
wants you're fat ass with diabetes
she gonna go eat a dialysis you fat
[ __ ] and he's like you see what i got
to deal with
it's just like he's napping broads he's
[ __ ] broad she's like we're gonna
have a baby yeah he's just like
and he's like yell in front of the baby
he's like the greatest [ __ ]
you know and and it's funny because he
was like and he's like his logic is like
wild he's like here's here's the mistake
you made chris
he's like you shouldn't have told your
mother he goes you shouldn't tell your
mother what you should
have did is he said you should have
introduced my girl's name is jasmine he
goes you shouldn't introduce her to
jasmine
okay don't say nothing about the
pregnancy because you introduce you to
jasmine he goes
let your mother get pregnant with the
idea of jazz would be pregnant
he goes you gotta he goes you got to
impregnate your mother with the idea of
jasmine beat and pregnancy it's actually
really fun and i was like that's hard
cause think about it three months in she
loves this broad all of a sudden oh we
have a baby not so big of a deal he goes
but now you bring this girl home
she's pregnant she's got a tattoo on the
tit what the [ __ ] going on
he goes he goes you're an idiot yeah but
that's tough if you go
if you just introduce him then your mom
hates her and then you get like well
yeah change of plan she's pregnant but
she doesn't though she doesn't know
that's the thing it's it's one of those
things where it's like when you have a
child
at least in my situation which i feel
very grateful and blessed is like my
child just
you you overcome the differences you may
have with one another for whatever
because we're like sure
we're raising a kid here so we got to
get over our [ __ ] you know what i
mean of course yeah
so so that's what's happened uh in my
life in
in my family with her and and you know
we'll see what happens with this [ __ ]
second kidnapping
i mean it plays it fast yeah because
that was one of those things too where
they were like my mother was like i
thought you and jasmine broke up i was
like we did
and she was like so i guess you're back
together now i was like
yeah you guys live together now yeah we
live together now yeah you guys moved in
so the kids there the whole night yeah
they have kids there and and she has has
a son from a previous relationship
so i'm kind of like a you know i am his
stepdad as well so it's like that's cool
i'm cool with his dad it's like
it's one of those things where it's like
you know i think
sometimes with my life people have said
i don't know how you deal with this i
don't know how you do it but like
because i'm in it i just am like happy
i'm like oh well i'll make it work i'm
just very warm sure yeah some people
think it's naive but i'm just like dude
what the [ __ ] like we can all like
aliens are getting lightweight
and kill us there's [ __ ] you know
covet everywhere it's like just shut up
like just be happy dude yeah that's how
i that's why i live my life
stick and move how old's the stepson
he's 10.
he's 10. he's 10. which is you know he
and now it's funny because he's at that
age now too where he's like
you're not my [ __ ] dad and i'm like
no i know
right you little [ __ ] i know i'm like
i'm not i'm like you know but
but i kind of even view him as instead
of viewing him as like a step
because i feel like sometimes when i say
step son or think about that like that's
the
that's the kind of trouble people get
into step fathers or step parents get
into where you're like
oh he's not he's not mine he's
i often call him my daughter's brother
so the connection is
for me so this is why it's like yes he's
not my child but he is my daughter's
brother and my daughter is my daughter
so it's like
i need to make sure this kid is great
and feels great cause he's gonna protect
my daughter when i'm not there i would
hope
so it's like daughter's brother so
that's the connection you know i come
i come uh but you know it's also it's
like not my kid so sometimes it's like
i wanna [ __ ] yell at this kid but i
can't so there's been plenty of times
where i'm like
[ __ ] i want to yell him and clean his
room but i'll just go in the bathroom
and jerk off you know
he's like yeah he lives with me too damn
three bedroom i got a [ __ ] three
betty baby look at you yes he does all
right
he's got a little bit of cash he's got a
little bit more how much cash you got on
you right now chris
right now right now carry cat you a cash
guy right now i got 600 in cash because
i sold merch at seoul joel's
last week when this morning no [ __ ] oh
this weekend but i got 600 in cash [ __ ]
face
because i sold [ __ ] t-shirts outside
their [ __ ] heated comedy dome
for pennsylvania 600. 600 yeah why are
you two
[ __ ] great the kid moves some shirts
kid can move team why do you still have
the cash on you
because i can't italian from bridgewood
that's the thing it's like you got to
have cash on you number one number two
it's like this [ __ ] government's not
going to tax my [ __ ] hashtag
get your message the government doesn't
know about it take a hike bernie that's
why i said 700 because it's really two
g's
why you said 600. yeah i'll do it every
time the camera's on me it's a different
number of cash i got in my [ __ ]
pocket
oh man holy you got five keys in your
new area
yeah yeah [ __ ] you got a duffel bag full
of cash
i got 20 bucks i sold 30 000 worth of
merch this weekend
it's a big deal
shout out to soldiers soldier's doing
great things he's doing they were out
there
for the first time i mean it's one of
those things but yeah i i
i started my career doing uh shows with
the great soul joel
and and it's one of those things where
it's like everybody's playing in joel's
world now
dude he's like the king of the east
coast he's doing he's making more money
than a lot of comedy clubs and i got to
be honest
you know tim dillon's going down there
you guys went down there louie was down
there it's like
go if you're looking i feel like
royersford pennsylvania's like
ari everybody goes on seoul jones.com go
go
yeah yeah that dome is pretty sweet the
dome is we were supposed
there's one guy with a [ __ ]
screwdriver trying to set that
literally like two hours before showtime
we're like this ain't gonna [ __ ]
happen so they just they just bailed on
we just had the heaters but it was
[ __ ] great
it was great yeah it was nice and then
when you guys go back if you go back in
the winter and do the
the dome now makes it like it's you feel
like you're inside yeah you know it's
perfectly safe and legal it's like the
the laughs don't dissipate they hit off
the top of the [ __ ] door
what we're doing with our lives is crazy
you're like nah the dome is pretty good
this
is pretty good i'm making money in
reuters
600 and kids moving merch pretty nice i
bought a house in roy's food with the
t-shirt
i could buy a neighborhood with the
t-shirt money and royers bought my own
dome
that's what it is chrissy's dome right
next door and you just bought a car
right do you have a sweet whip
i got a sweet whip i well here's the
thing i got chrissy new money
yeah absolutely yeah uh yeah you've had
cash
you've been doing well for because we
moved up you were like just yeah you
were not in new york
i i would tell you he used to roll
around the village with a couple of
smoke shows
it's what it is cut that part out
no i'm kidding i used to be qui listen
everybody knows even my girl knows
my nickname used to be chrissy drip drop
it's just what it is and
some of them you know it's just like i
liked you know what's one of those
things too
about about about like yeah you know
when i was single whatever hooking up
with girls it's like
you know people like oh there's a lot of
girls like you know like whatever it's
like
you know they're involved too it's like
you know as much lonely sex as
as people like oh that's lonely you're a
sex addict it's like we all like [ __ ]
that's ugly people talk i know i know
it's like people saying
it's like dude it's like you know we
would kind of you know
you listen there was definitely times
it's like you use sex to [ __ ]
to replace a drug or whatever but it's
like the women's doing it like we're
both doing it it's like it's like
sometimes it's a mutual uh it's a mutual
sex thing i'm like yeah like
but there was a time where i was like it
was getting a little out of control it's
like you can't have
five girls that you hooked up with show
up at the comedy cellar well i don't
know i remember
uh 38 years old we got to new york after
being in philly for
30 years i was 38. right and we're doing
[ __ ] shows at the lantern [ __ ]
living off dollar slice pizza
go over to the [ __ ] cellar and see
you and schultz [ __ ] running around
just like
all right like [ __ ] right that's what
mtv was [ __ ] yeah i'd love to work
for andrew schultz right now yeah
what's up chelsea schultz yeah i'm sorry
i'm not wearing your merch
shout out tim dillon no but you've been
doing a team show
and i will say about schultz though oh
we love him
and i'm sure a lot of people he's a big
mentor and people know this about him or
not but like just if you know
i was someone who who's worked with
andrew when for years guy code
when guy code and girl code came out
which was very popular shows on on mtv
back in 2011 12 13
schultz the vision that schultz schultz
is one of the examples of someone who
i've known
i've watched him from the beginning come
up where he the vision that he had for
himself he had
eight years ago when we were doing mtv
guy code when he
didn't give a [ __ ] when he was doing the
guy code girl code and then
going on the road not selling as many
tickets but he didn't care he believed
in the
he believed in the podcast and the
youtube product before anybody
saw it he knew exactly what was coming
and now it's one of those things where
it's like you know people think schultz
is
is overnight or the people just saw him
on netflix phone it's like no no
schultz that's the shelter he's been
murdering in new york for a decade
twice schultz has been 10 12 15 years at
this so it's like one of those things
where it's like
for guys like me like his his peers or
guys that came up with him
everybody respect schultz because you're
like this guy worked for every single
ounce of
what he has hustled because the guy
called girl code stuff
it it did well for us and it made our
twitter numbers go up and instagram
numbers go up but not the ticket sales
the ticket sales was all his
methodical plan so it's it's it's cool
to watch that's the stage of the career
i'm at now where like
people who i used to do the village
lantern with or
the maui taco or you know we used to do
the laugh lounge i don't know if you
guys
that was gone like all those guys are
now like snl
and movie directors and all these people
or like humongous comedians and it's
like
so now i'm at the stage where it's like
oh my peers are like becoming like
the the way like the next chappelle
serious people it's like so that so i'm
seeing now
how i was always because i was always
like when i first started i was like oh
man like there's a lot of like nepotism
and it's all like
these friends like how do they all know
each other but now you see you just stay
around like you're there
yeah so it's a war of attrition it's
like a hangout yeah you've known the
people for a decade yeah it's like now
it's like it's like you know you you
know people be like i can't believe you
have this guy's number that person
number is like these are my been my
friends like we used to
literally do open mics like i've i've
had to there's been
i had to go do a gig once in pittsburgh
pennsylvania with schultzy and this guy
pudge fernandez who was great and there
was too many people in the car i
i was in the trunk for four hours to get
to a gig in pittsburgh pennsylvania with
children's
trunks yeah because i was like i would
get shotgun i was the biggest one
well no because she's [ __ ] skinny
little [ __ ] and i and i was [ __ ] i
was 250 back then
get a little meat on it but schultzy
with this [ __ ] keto diet yeah i want
to get i want to print out one of his
old uh head shots and put it back here
on the set oh yeah yeah dude
so but but that's one of those guys so
all these guys that are doing great now
with these
podcast visions and all that it's like
i'm happy to be a part of like
the crew in a way i guess but it's like
but it's like you know
none of this [ __ ] is overnight dude like
i did
i did for years bro i've done
the [ __ ] comedy central half hour
hour the letterman stuff the tv stuff
i didn't i would go to cities and there
would be i would sometimes have to give
money back to the club because of how
little tickets i saw
sorry about that it wasn't until i
started doing exactly what you guys are
doing
exactly on the path of what you guys are
doing is amazing
thank you that's when the tickets
started to come and that's when it
started to become like lifelong fans
where it's like
yeah they mention this or that or
whatever but it's like even now like i
just i'm gonna host
a show on on truetv and my family's like
congratulating me because i
i always call myself chrissy pilots i've
had nine pilots this is the first one
that ever went so now i'm [ __ ]
chrissy pickups
chrissy up front just right away so this
is the first this is the first one that
ever got on the air so
while i'm absolutely joyous about it and
feel good about it it's like
one of those things where like because
my family doesn't understand the
business but right
i they called me to tell me the show got
picked up and i was a little like
[ __ ] now what am i gonna do about the
podcast no it's of course
because it's like i'm losing money to do
a tv show you know
but yeah but well it's also like the
relationship you build with the podcast
people
yes you're never you could you could
host a thousand tv shows for a thousand
seasons and you'll never build that
never
never build that rapport never so it's
like the podcast audience is like what
you know it's the people you talk to
it's like they're your real fans they're
the ones that like
through this pandemic it's like when
some of my other peers who like don't
have that or
who've chased the other dreams which is
and fine whatever you want to do but
it's like
they're becoming it's getting to the
point where financially i'm sure they're
starting
trouble yeah where me it's like we never
blinked twice because the fans were like
no we're here dude like we'll take five
dollars on my stimulus check and go put
it on your patreon whatever it is like
so so like dude i mean you know we blew
up through the it was like we started
this two weeks before
[ __ ] quarantine like what the [ __ ]
are we going to do
and now the other things will come from
this yeah so that's the thing like
any time like and schultz would say the
same thing he was saying this 10 years
ago i got to give him credit
like any time like these executives want
to chime in and people who aren't in
comedy want to
it's never good but now it's like you do
things there's no rule you edit yourself
yeah
so that's like that's why everything
everything you put out is like at least
it's like
nobody told me not to do that so that's
when i'd rather live and die with that
than
be in a box i mean the tv show i'm doing
the tv show
even the only reason why i even said yes
to doing the tv show is because it's in
los angeles i'm like oh i'll get on the
la pod there you go yeah that's why i
did it
you know i was like yeah yeah that makes
sense
dude well like even with this like he's
like he he's very generous to schultzy
with like just like knowledge and like
every move
we because we saw like what you guys
have what he has like what tim built
like all these guys that built his like
universes i was like oh [ __ ] that's what
we want to do so you know i texted
showtime like i'm thinking about
because we were with the network i'm
like i'm thinking about doing this and
he's like yeah i think that's the
like right he's like that's the [ __ ] go
independent you gotta go independent
because it's like
you just and also like this is one of
those things where it's like it's it's
it's kind of like this little thing of
ours you know where it's
where it's like no managers no agents
it's nothing it's like
we do it and we collect all the money
it's also like even like even this week
like tim tim has another show when he
[ __ ]
it's like everybody kind of it is a
supportive environment yeah it's like
dude schultzy has been super supportive
ahri's been super sure of giannis
giannis has made 15 posts about the
[ __ ] podcast nobody nobody
ever yeah nobody's jealous or nobody's
like you know every
when you're secure in what you're doing
you know what i mean yeah
you know it's like it's like an old
situation i think like a lot this is
just a life thing too it's like you're
never in competition with anybody you
really are only
learn that as you get as you get further
along it's just like
it's like even if we're going out for
the same role it's like we never really
were in competition with each other it's
just like
you create that [ __ ] in our head we
create it in our head it's like
you getting a huge podcast doesn't take
away from anybody else's podcast it's
your own stuff
there's enough room for all of us it may
not feel that way but it's like dude
even even sometimes you know there's
what is there [ __ ]
seven billion people in the world it's
like even sometimes with my own podcast
i'm like oh man you know we got a
hundred thousand downloads like
you know are we ever going to get any
more fans like what yeah what do you
hundred thousand dollars like [ __ ] you
your pocket
there's not even a hundred thousand
people that live on my block you know
what i mean
it's like it's like most people have
never heard of me
so it's just like that but it's like we
have this thing where it's like nuts
oh everybody's doing podcasts now at
saturday it's like no it's not it's like
so what if there's 300 podcasts there's
billions of people in the world yeah
you know look at this chrissy wisdom
that's what it is
yeah i love it sitting down with the
youngsters start straightening them out
dude [ __ ] schulte i'm team chrissy from
here and
for me is i'll jerk everybody off again
that's the kind of service i do
i make sure everybody's balls are
drained i've got two little pee-pees at
the table so you might you're better off
with b-bone back there
t-bone's got a unit you got you got to
have it you got to have a nice one right
i would say
you got big dick you're a big you're a
big dude well what happened was is i
measured it i'm
seven normally eight with warts that's
right that's what it is
when the hpv pops up i go to eight yeah
get a little beefy get a little beefy
bones got a hog on him yeah what's the
word on the street really
nice fat conch oh yeah and circumcised
too right
oh dude what hippie parents i got the
[ __ ]
uncut extended edition bro wild man
i don't know if i could do that yeah
well i didn't like it i talked my
my wife is your pitch she's from germany
and they're all uncut
right and then she's like i'm like we
have a boy where i'm [ __ ] he can't i
can't have a guy by myself
yeah i'm like we're doing it she's like
well i don't know i'm like listen
he can't be going to like to shower in
gym class with an uncut piece dude one
of my closest friends was born and
raised well
born in poland and came here when he was
seven so he didn't get circumcised this
kid got circumcised
he was 18 years old my dad's friend did
the same thing he was like 50 in the
garage the [ __ ]
yeah dude my this kid he got circumcised
for a girlfriend he was like oh my
girlfriend said she won't you know
she won't have sex with me unless i get
circumcised what and i was like what and
he didn't tell anybody that and then he
just shows up one day to
to school on crutches and i was like
he's in a wheelchair i was like what's
going on with you he's like i hurt my
back
i was like and i was you know starting
to do physical therapies like you
wouldn't be on crutches if you hurt your
back
he goes ah it's my knee and then i
[ __ ] was like is it your back your
knee dude
he was like you promised you're not
gonna make a big deal out of it i was
like yeah of course i'm your best friend
he goes i got circus i was like let me
see your [ __ ] dick right now
and this kid what it looked like bro he
pulled it out in the background
making my blood wrong oh it looked like
an isis beheading video like
it was i can picture this scab and it's
got a cigarette
because he's got a little pp2 but this
thing got swollen
so four or five times the size i was
like how do you pee goes bro it's a big
problem he goes i keep peeing on the
wound
because his dick was like all the way
pushed back in he's like i keep peeing
in my own wound
and i'm like dude why did you gotta if
you got if you got a little pp on you
why you
why are you trimming off the top you
gotta you gotta take it out you can get
it and how about this the girlfriend
dumped him like three weeks later what
the
[ __ ] is that that she wouldn't [ __ ] him
because he had he was uncircumcised
he goes and gets the surgery that's
gotta take a month you can't [ __ ]
yeah the next day with three four weeks
later i thought i'm not getting the car
detailed
that's serious business i think he may
be had sex with her once or twice more
and then it was over what can you do
[ __ ] i don't blame her those things are
tough looking dude
for all my uncut brethren out there hang
tough and [ __ ] jewish [ __ ] it's
hilarious
tell her you're jewish oh you show up
with that thing oh my god
ah it's a different sect yeah all right
let's get into some questions yeah we
got to get into some questions here i
want to ask you
i alluded to the beginning but do you
think you're garbage
do i think i'm garbage then and now do
you think you came from garbage
that's a pretty cause you know there's a
big dichotomy there with your mother and
your father
you're extremely educated yes you got
some money
right got killed i i think that my
hypothesis here is you're less trash
than your
pro your mom seems like a class act and
i assume you're sorry
i assume you had money growing up your
mom had a good job
my mom had my mom had a good job i
wouldn't say i had money
but i i wasn't i certainly wasn't poor
like i got what i wanted for christmas
but i wouldn't say
i didn't go to private school i went to
catholic school which is different than
private journal so i did that but i
wouldn't say i necessarily had money but
i i wasn't poor i would say
i am guar i would say i'm i'm garbage
but with one of those scented hefty bags
okay so they're not like a those are
real [ __ ] not as bad as the neighbors
i would say a scented a nice scented
housing
or maybe a simple human which is a more
upscale garbage can
but stainless you're in a stainless
steel can right but i would say but for
sure but
but you know i would say still garbage
because i mean still
most events like big events in my life
if i did something good i'd be taken to
the red lobster for celebration dude i
literally have one here have you been to
the red lobster so that so i
i don't think you can consider yourself
not garbage for my 18th birthday i went
to the red lobster
with all the places in queens and your
dad and the italian you go to red
lobsters this is what it is red lobster
and with my mom not my father
on my other side we very freak we
frequent in the olive garden a lot so
what what nationality is your mom my mom
is like irish irish german yeah
where they say irish they don't you know
they go to olive garden outback
steakhouse lobster
yeah you know karate are you are you
close at your pop side of the family yes
and they're all hardcore italian pretty
hardcore italian sunday gravy the whole
night all that stuff yeah yeah so they
didn't really know about the olive
garden stuff also the first
also the first car i ever had was a
toyota corolla so that's garbage
you know and i had a reliable car ran
forever i bet i had a toyota i had a
toyota i upgraded to a camry but i had a
toyota camry in 2016 which is not that
long ago yeah you were making it you
were making more than camry i i had
already done the mtv stuff
and all that like i i had done david
letterman and i drove to david letterman
in a toyota corolla
you drove yourself that's a queens
right there because this is the thing
they send a car don't they no it's
garbage
here's the thing garbage [ __ ] stuff i
felt and i got to tip the driver
right i felt because i was coming from
again i just didn't know
i felt because i was coming from staten
island my agent said well
they can they'll send the car to
wherever you go i said yeah but i'm
standing and they got to pay the toll
over the verrazano
i'll drive in and i drove in i got easy
pass don't worry i got the easy pass i
drove in and i spent 50 bucks to put in
a garage none of it was needed
yeah it probably only made like 900. how
about this too i go to do david
letterman
show i have i thought it was a good set
was riding high
what do i do take my car drive down to
the village lantern bomb in front of
five swedish people
a lantern will get you man r.i.p to the
lantern it's
oh it's back i don't know that guy's
shifting you guys you can't get the
lantern nah
you won't get it right now no no no no
no nuclear holocaust
doesn't matter dude i feel like you're
the type of dude who would walk out of
an opera take off your suit jacket and
shoot dice in the alley
yeah yeah i i'm one of those guys yeah
well that brings up a question do you
have a suit right now that if you ought
to go to a funeral tomorrow you have a
suit that fits you
look again i hate to i hate to bring it
up again but if you go watch the david
letterman show 2013
chris stefano david letterman the suit
that i'm wearing is a suit that i bought
off the rack at joseph a bank that
morning
wow oversized it's the biggest suit it's
oversized it literally
steve harvey suit my agent said to me
she i was dressed right
i i think i was already mic'd up she was
like is that what you're wearing out
there
i was like is this bad joseph a
bank i drew joseph bought it from a
strip mall in
in uh suffolk county long island and
then went to my dad's on staten island
yeah joseph a bank or joseph a bank and
what's the other one men's warehouse
that was high men's warehouse is all
right right joseph a bank is like yeah
you buy one shirt we give you 15 for
free and it's just yeah joseph
subscription joseph a bank shared a wall
with the chuck e cheese
i did that for my first television
appearance ever in my life
yeah sorry i would say
so i don't have a but but do you say you
that's the only suit you own
i do have a if if i need to put on a
suit right now
i would say no because i put on a few
pounds but you have okay so you have i
have designer suits like [ __ ] i could
versace
no no i could squish tim dillon hoodie i
could squeeze it to a suit yeah yeah
exactly what the [ __ ] nice sweatshirt
[Laughter]
what about jeans don't you spend because
you're honest because we were asking
giannis
because i always think giannis dress is
sharp but he says the shoe dresser
should i buy cheap jeans it's the shoes
but he said you you'll drop what's the
most you ever spent on jeans
on jeans nah dude i'm 30 40 bucks but
what because what but what because i'm
because here's the thing i've changed
the thing
i'm all about athleisure now i'm chrissy
lululemon so i've spent
i spent 110 on lulu's no problem because
it feels like the future athleisure is
what i'm about
so the only reason he said that without
without trying to be funny
yeah leisure is what about that i'm with
it man
ever since this quarantine i've been
sweatpants most of the time i don't know
if i'm ever going back
athleisure dude i come on the only
reason why i don't have my lulu's today
is because it's [ __ ] laundry day
because you know
she's pregnant now so she's only does it
once a week you got a washer and dryer
in the wash your dryer in units big for
new york that is what about a dishwasher
got it all done
are you in bay ridge now bay original
yeah yeah yeah now the big thing for new
yorkers giannis did it
or you think do you think about moving
out to the burbs
to the birds long island you go jersey
here's the thing giannis would say the
country the country i had an offering
for a house on staten island
i pulled out last minute but now we're
actively looking at homes on long island
yeah
so i'm probably going to move to the
burbs just because it's not that i'm
escaping the city i think
new york's dead none of that it's just
you know it becomes to the point where
it's like
i didn't grow up with a backyard and a
pool i want my daughter and
and my stepson and the new child to have
all those things i didn't have i want
them to have a [ __ ] play area
you know that's what i want i don't know
is the house some of the houses you're
looking at they have pools
yeah well yeah it's a requirement they
got to have pools he's crispy
cul-de-sacs
that's what it is yeah yeah
and yeah well that's in-ground pool i
assume you could do
if you can't you you you could not go
above ground
no in ground pool come on in ground pool
but i'm so trash i may put an above
brown pool next to the in-ground pool
just so my kids know that above ground
in the front yard you know where you
came from
dude he's got an above ground pulled
himself and i swear to god i am not
[ __ ] with you
they built a deck the whole backyard is
a deck to make it an
in-ground pool well that's above ground
in ground i looked at a house in
in in a town on long island and they
said it's an in-ground pool and i took
one look i said that's a [ __ ] deck
the real estate agent said no and i
[ __ ] went down
to the to the foundation and i found the
little door and i opened it up and i
said look at that
what's this that's an in-ground pool
he's like oh i thought it wasn't i
thought it was in a i thought it was an
issue
it's an above ground i'm not getting
chrissy real estate like that i'll tell
you that right now
yeah i know i've seen flipping and
shipping yeah i know this [ __ ]
all right i gotta it's always a great
episode when we barely get to the
questions
um we gotta get to them well you know uh
what'd you get on your sats
my sats i got a
i wanna say [ __ ] you know what i don't
remember i will say i don't remember the
score but i didn't park it i did get
into
i think i got whatever i got into i got
i must have gotten at least a thousand
because out of 1600 which isn't you know
that's
right you got to be four digits i got
into all the colleges i applied that
yeah then you probably gotta work
together
st joseph's college in downtown brooklyn
where i met where i went uh
suny maritime which was which is a
military
[ __ ] submarine yeah the [ __ ] is that
yeah
yeah cape cod chrissy out there yeah
yeah it was [ __ ] sunny maritime which
is where i was gonna
the scurvies yeah [ __ ] yeah i was gonna
go and then i actually got into
pepperdine university in malibu because
i was gonna go
literally i swear to god dude i was
going to go away to school i was going
to go into
i was just going to go to california and
do it and then i genuinely
i never accept you know i never said i
accepted st joe's because i
genuinely was at that point hadn't
really ever been away from home
i was scared at that point in my life
and still kind of them now but i was
scared at that point to sleep alone in
the dark
so i didn't i didn't i'm a little afraid
of this i didn't want to be 3 000 miles
away from my mother
i was 18 years old with no night light
yeah so i stayed home i dude i slept on
the floor i slept with my mom till like
maybe i was 10 11 years old like it was
a little uncomfortable like
where i remember my mom because my mom
was single she had like you know
boyfriends
where they were like you know i remember
one when my one of her boyfriends like
you know
i can't be in a relationship with a
woman whose 12 year old son is still
sleeping on the floor in her bedroom
and i was like what the [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out there
[ __ ] beat it loser yeah
me and my teddy bear going in yeah
[ __ ]
okay all right um fights growing up as a
kid
i got into two really big fights
one fist fight i got into um i went
there was uh
this kid glenn who was like a really
strong [ __ ] kid
who was just talking so much [ __ ] about
my cousin and he was sick
and he it's always somebody talking [ __ ]
about somebody about somebody
and he was and we were riding bikes and
we stopped at a light and he was sitting
on his bike and i said the only
move i'm gonna have the only chance i'm
gonna have to win to defend my cousin's
honor is to punch him in the face
right now knock him off his bike and
maybe like a car
drive by and run over his head or
something and i'll win the fight and you
know kid stuff
and i punched him i punched him in the
side of the head
nice which did no damage it hurt my
knuckles he didn't even flinch
well he flinched looked at me and then
picked up his bike and started choking
me
the with the part of his bike you know
the frame of his bike started choking me
until i started to cry that's one fight
and then the second fight is on 9 11
when i broke the chair over the kid's
head okay
it's the only time so and there was a
couple of times i got into fights
playing basketball because basketball
was a huge part of my life playing high
school college all that
but those i don't really sports fights i
don't really count actual fifty shots
only really two what were the the injury
injuries as a kid
what happened never broke a bone or
anything like that still to this day
but i've sprained my ankles both ankles
like six seven times each so i have no
because when you break a bone the bone
will grow back like three times as
strong and your
body gets stronger after a bone break
cartilage damage and ligament damage
just makes your ankles
weak so now when i put my feet down like
my feet just fall to the side
like that like i have the type of feet
and giannis has said this multiple times
where
my feet look broken like i look like i
have two broken feet
but i don't i have two sprained ankles
it's got baboon feet i got that feet so
i've never i've never broken a i've
never broken a bone
and and i've never um i've never been
knocked unconscious
really i don't think i have either the
only time the only time i even even had
anesthesia was two years ago when i had
to get a colonoscopy
for pleasure colonoscopy that young that
young but it was it was a false
alarm i literally i was you know having
a lot of anxiety at the time of my life
and i thought that i was [ __ ] like
red and i thought all different colors
and this and that and i would take
pictures of my [ __ ] and send them to
a doctor and he was like look i can't
really tell if this is just like
the [ __ ] flash on your iphone yeah or
like if there's something else in the
toilet bowl but it it doesn't look great
off the pictures so like why don't we
just do it and if it's no
if and if i don't see anything come back
when you're 50. and that's what happened
he did he didn't he didn't see anything
not too bad but it was good well he
found like one polyp or something like
that but he said that's nothing
yeah from the neighborhood yeah yeah
it's [ __ ]
nothing keep it moving chris yeah uh all
right have you ever worn a dog tag
necklace
a dog tag they were big in the 90s no
i do have on two chains now though like
i have two chains on at all times that's
so i did but i never i've never worn a
dog tag
uh uh necklace no i don't not that i can
remember
is there a cross on one of those chains
there there is but it's in the shop
so there normally is but i i got it
broke what happened
my daughter just you know [ __ ] around
with the jewelry and stuff so she
scuffed it up there was a little scuff
mark on jesus's knee and it can't have
that
crucifix has to be you know pristine
pristine
yeah yeah go ahead kip uh have you ever
had a rat tail haircut as a kid
i've never had a rat tail as a kid but i
have had mushroom haircuts
i would nor i would go to supercuts a
lot and ask for one of the numbers on
the board
for a long time yeah
that's tough lines in your head lines in
my head yes i had line in my head i
had a line in my head uh uh four months
ago in the pandemic i've had a line i've
asked for the barber to put a lot
ironically or
just because you know i [ __ ] just i
don't know
i'm chrissy linehead have you ever had a
line in your eyebrow
yeah no i haven't had a line in my
eyebrow but i did want to shave bolting
my eyebrows off
wow i look like i had cancer i don't
know anthony soprano what the [ __ ]
yeah it's just [ __ ] somebody i forgot
what it was somebody said that i had a
unibrow on my eyebrows whatever and i i
was like 19 20 years old and i went in
the bathroom and i shaved both of my
eyebrows off
and i remember my dad came and picked me
up for basketball practice he was like
what the [ __ ] happened to his face
i was like i shaved my eyebrows off he
was like why i was like i don't know
that's great yeah
so i shaved my eyebrows off once but
i've never had a line in the eyebrow
okay
all right uh anyone in your family
collect the state quarters
the state quarters what do you mean by
that like they came out probably in the
2000s it was like you know alabama and
then hawaii
no nobody collects the state quarters
but i do know every state capital
that's really that's one for punishment
if i would get in trouble what my mother
would do is lock me in my bedroom and
she had the key from the outside and i
have to recite the state capital
and read the encyclopedia for [ __ ]
two hours and it literally
if if i was an hour and 55 minutes in
and i stopped
like thinking like there's no way she's
still listening if two seconds will go
by and you would hear
continue she would just sit out there
doing god knows what maybe crocheting or
eating her own dinner just being like
this that was her form of punishment
because she's an academic
so i know these i know these random
facts because of her she'd lock you in
your room
and make me [ __ ] decide to stay
outside [ __ ] my mom
yeah yeah sybil
any tap out gear any tap out gear no but
i do have ed hardy shirts
you do still what are you still to this
day really i have a couple of bad hearty
shirts with little rhodes but no tap out
gear i actually don't know anything
really about the ufc or fighting okay
have you ever worn an airbrush t-shirt
an airbrushed t-shirt um like what's
that like a tie-dye shirt like what's
the
airbrush would be like you see like they
get like the rip shirt it's like uh
how do you describe that on the
boardwalk
um yeah but like kind of like let's say
like chrissy d or whatever like yeah but
yeah yes but that's like with family
stuff like oh we got all by matching
shirts i've done that stuff
really i've done this stuff and i also
am the guy like i'll i will religiously
still to this day if i'm performing in
let's say philly every time even though
i've done it so many times i will get on
a double decker bus tour and go on the
tour
i do that every time really into
whatever city i'm in i look for some
type of either double decker bus tour
or if it's like a [ __ ] town some type of
walking tour
of the city i always do that i always
usually in the airport will buy some
kind of magnet or shot glass from
wherever i'm at
yeah yeah that's insane that's [ __ ]
awesome
yeah while i'm on the road like actively
i'll do i'll do it i'm you know i'm
going gonna be in phoenix in [ __ ] two
weeks i'll get on the
tour i have a kind of a travel one have
you ever gotten the free breakfast at a
hotel you weren't a guest at well i
wasn't a guest at multiple times
especially in the beginning when i first
started headlining absolutely dude yeah
of course i mean i'm not [ __ ] making
eight hundred dollars you know
roll through the continental you do that
and which i didn't even know that the
continental
i thought that a continental breakfast
meant that it was free but it doesn't
mean that at all
so there's been times where i went to a
hotel had the continental breakfast
ate it all went back up to my room then
got charged i'm like why are you
charging me for free [ __ ] they're like
it's not free because it's just because
it means continental did you know that
no i thought continental meant it was
free no continental means that it's from
all different parts of the world like
the food is just like yeah i think it's
described as the food not the price
no you have to say free continental free
continental i didn't know that
i i thought continental you never gone
and got like a continental car wash you
know what i mean like it's not like a
word you can just
substitute for free no i think
continental means like there's no actual
main dish it's like bagels and [ __ ] like
that
yeah it describes the food but it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't mean
that's free
complimentary kind of like there was
goulash down there what
different continents i don't know but it
ain't free i know that much
apparently how do you feel about
fettuccine alfredo
fettuccine alfredo how do i feel about
it i ate it last night
i swear to god my go-to dish is
fettuccine alfredo with grilled chicken
or grilled shrimp if i'm trying to be
healthy and a side of garlic nuts
wait you ordered it out i uh oh yeah
ordered out either uh donuts pizzeria or
nino's pizzeria and bay ridge
sometimes gino's pizzeria they have
great fettuccine alfredo and
great potato croquettes dude it's one of
the things about new york i
tell everybody this but nobody ever
believes me most local pizza places
their
actual food their italian food is
usually [ __ ] top shelf
unbelievable unbelievable jana said this
too about me said you're the kind of guy
your favorite cuisine is like
other like off the menu pizza stuff or
other side of the menu pizzeria
so a lot of people go into a pizzeria
they order the pizza or whatever it's
like i'm looking at the menu
yeah but what kind of rolls they have
what kind of pasta dishes
i'm looking at the entrees into pizza
all day place next to my apartment as
[ __ ]
their shrimp front face is [ __ ]
unbelievable amazing dude top shelf
um all right i got one i got one that
we've done before we did with shoulder
and you i've seen you
in professional sports jerseys do you
rock jersey that's what i do
yeah yeah so let's it's a hypothetical
right if you were going to a wedding
tomorrow and didn't have a suit the only
thing you could wear
okay was a professional sports jersey
hockey baseball
football you know whatever what would
you choose and why
i would choose i would most likely wear
my favorite baseball player bernie
williams center field of new york
yankees bernie williams batting practice
jersey
because i wear the batting practice
jerseys because they make me look jacked
even though i'm not jack
i am what i am when i take my shirt off
it's a surprise
people are like oh i didn't i didn't
think it was going to be that doughy
i've casting director said this to me
once and it was like literally like life
changing i was like that's the most
painful and also funny thing
i've heard and it's like does describe
me he's like you know what your problem
is chris you have leading man face best
friend body
he was like so you're really not
castable what a [ __ ] dick but he was
right he's like so either you got it so
it motivates you to me to try to create
my own [ __ ] he's like because you're
really not gasping it's like either
[ __ ] be the lead and get ripped
or [ __ ] let it all hang out fat [ __ ]
best friend
so that's what i do i wear bernie
williams new york yankees batting
practice journey would you tuck it in
or would you go on time no i go untucked
and i throw in i throw on some lulu's
i'll tell you exactly what i do i go
bernie williams banning practice jersey
lululemon pants some type of funky red
or orange socks to give it a little
flare
and [ __ ] um um fry boots because it's
a wedding
i gotta class it up a little bit um big
tip guy
big tip guy i'm the guy i over tip i
tip [ __ ] everybody oh cash full cash
i'm the guy
even if i get driven somewhere or
whatever if i don't have cash on me i
make them stop at an atm and i give
these guys
cold hard cash because we talked about
that on ya yana said you were breaking
his balls
because he said he didn't tip and what i
mean
somewhere yeah it's he's like chris yell
at me it's like what are we doing like
you know they're sending you a black car
i mean he's like no but the tips
included i'm like
you got to give this guy cash tips what
are you a [ __ ] [ __ ] queen
you get that from your dad your dad a
big tip guy oh my god big time i mean my
dad will give him aliens
love cats dude my dad is that my dad was
the guy he would pull he would and for
no
my dad would religiously wear pants
and jackets and things that had pockets
but put his wallet in a sock
i'm like what's the reason to do that
why is [ __ ] always coming so
every drive anywhere you went somebody
would get a soggy
[ __ ] ankle sweat 20 thrown right on
their lap
he puts his smile on me he gets hemmed
up you know what i mean
no but the thing and you know really too
my dad but also you know again one of
the good things about this business is
sometimes you get to meet your own
heroes especially doing in new york and
colin quinn has always been especially
where i'm from like huge hero of mine
and now we're like close friends work
together whatever and the way colin
quinn tips is like it makes me feel like
a [ __ ]
really this guy will give somebody 200
cash nope for bringing him a pizza no
problem
he doesn't give a [ __ ] sorry he spit
[ __ ] give a [ __ ] i [ __ ] love you
yeah
what about a wedding you go to a wedding
friend close friend
family right what's usually in the
envelope
you're taking a date i'm taking this one
of course you got to play
i got to pay for my table two plates two
plates what are you what are you
dropping
i'm gonna drop four close friend we're
saying
you go you want the yawn oh giannis
might be two parts yeah like you know
maybe uh somebody you grew up with put
it down yeah i would say
giannis giannis gets a g close friend
gets five hundred
yeah holy [ __ ] cash i mean [ __ ] celeb
we're celebrating love here baby
a g he gets a g cash easy
and [ __ ] and a friend gets 500. now
what if you weren't chrissy d what if
you were doctor
dr chris dr chris still have cash
probably i would still find a way to
listen if i have the means to do it i i
would do it if
i would give as much as i as i could
what's the least you would give
that you would that you would consider
you're embarrassed
or you wouldn't go you're coming to my
wedding what are you dropping
if i was coming to your wedding and i
was down on my luck
i'd give you 300 cash with a post that
says i'm really sorry i'm embarrassed
i get i i yeah i'd give you 300 yeah you
know i ordered the chicken not the steak
and i didn't have the dessert yeah
haley had two drinks 300 cash with a
little [ __ ] chip
with a little recording from sebastian
manukau saying aren't you
embarrassed wow that's [ __ ] clever
300k
i come to your wedding you're going to
get 300 is the minimum and i'm giving
the bartender 100 to
[ __ ] hook me up all night you start
starting to think that's
the first thing you do hit them heavy as
you put and i'll remember you
i say look here's what it is this is
what it is all night that's what i want
okay four eyes all night because it's
like really cause in the grand scheme of
things
i look at it as i spent 400 for a fun
night out
if it was going to be make or break i
can't go around with that i can't do it
but
400 uh money is money you can make 400
bucks i'm not sure i'm like 400 i don't
think is gonna make or break my life so
it's like
we're out of marriage celebrating love
why not just have a if i went out on the
town and [ __ ] dinners drinks i might
spend that anyway
so you know why don't i give it to these
[ __ ] people probably just you know
this poor girl's father just spent 100k
on this [ __ ] wedding she's gonna
divorce this guy in three years anyway
you know talk about celebrating love
yeah
it's never gonna work here's a hundred
here's a hundo keep it moving
lasting so so far am i moving am i going
towards garbage
i'm on the fence i don't know i'm not on
the fence i can't get a read on you
yeah that's what it is well that's why
you're saying what are you leaning on
chrissy
[ __ ] class all the way wow i haven't
heard one [ __ ] thing
he's gonna [ __ ] dock all right how
about this if i went to your house right
now
well the batting practice jersey was a
little [ __ ] that was hypothetically
you backed him
i know buddy he shouted out the exact
jersey yeah
exact jersey or i'd either wear that or
i would wear a [ __ ]
even though he's not on the t actually
you know what i'd either wear that this
might push
the garbage i knew this is going to be
good because this is true because i i
also feel like sometimes i look tight
and jacked in this one too
i might wear a [ __ ] i might wear a
cal clutter buck islanders jersey
i'm an islanders fan so that pushes you
towards garbage if you're an island
feidelberg from barstow said he would do
that because they're called sweaters he
goes it's technically a sweater you're
wearing a sweater to a formal event
i put on a clutter buck island just
jersey so i don't but if i'm just being
honest but what was the other question
about my house
uh we went to your house right now both
of us you invited us in we sit down
we asked for water what are you giving
us you got a bottle you got a brita is
it coming straight out of the tap what
are you doing
i got a uh a poland spring um uh like
dispenser
you do i got water and i also got is it
chilled or is it just regular chilled
wow cold water and i also have poland
spring it's called poland spring origin
i get nestle nestle poland spring i get
two weeks every two weeks they deliver
you know the the gallons of water to my
house with poland spring origin which is
the it's the i can't explain it to you
it's i would get baptized in this
[ __ ] shirt
the water high end poland spring water
so you would get water i'd also offer
you poland spring cell type pollen
springs celsius pole spring origin water
and i have a pawn spring dispenser
you're not getting tap water in my house
i'm not going to put a [ __ ] brit off
what about the fridge is it did you have
two doors on the fridge or one
right now currently two right now
currently one door every house i've
looked at
on long island has a two-door fridge
it's it's it's it's a necessity for my
girl
sure yeah i imagine the yeah this is
[ __ ] close
the house i imagine is impeccably clean
and the house
the house is impeccably clean but i got
to give that to my girl that's that's
really her
friend you have everything lined up like
on cribs when you open the fridge
all that [ __ ] because of her because of
her she has all that [ __ ] lined up and
you know she's puerto rican so it's
[ __ ] you know she
she'll have a [ __ ] full dead chicken
yeah right
live chickens hanging upside down in the
kids bedrooms
cause we're having boy bites later yeah
she cooks great really she cooks great
and you know what she does which is
[ __ ] nice and it's a rare thing
she can and she's doing it done it
better than anyone i've ever tasted she
can mix
latin cuisine with italian so i've had
fettuccine alfredo with
latin spices in it and it's like un
[ __ ] believable
wow she'll do [ __ ] like that she'll make
you know she'll make like um
some type of bean dish but somehow it
tastes like italian food i don't know
how she does it
some bean dish beans some rice and beans
she's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
shoes off in the house shoes off in the
house wow that's again yeah you got it
there's a whole shoe rack right off and
again i
again i i got to give credit with chris
you that that's really her
she won't let you you know you can't
walk in because she's like you know what
i mean your daughter's on the floor here
we can't have shoes in the house sure
all right pretty good
ever use a fork to scratch your back
i've never used a fork to scratch my
back but i do use a fork to eat chinese
food
i don't use chopsticks i don't think
that
disqualifies anything
if i'm going to do sushi because that's
the thing it's like my grandfather
fought in world war ii it's like
to the day he died he thought the
japanese were still the enemy so in an
honor to him i like sushi it's [ __ ]
healthy for me it's i'm crissy
cholesterol it helps lower my
cholesterol
but because i want to just prove to him
and if he's looking down at me that i'm
american i eat that [ __ ] with a fork
i will not they give me a chopstick i
say wrong country babe
bring me the fork and i only get amer
and i only get the roles that have
american names i only get a philadelphia
role of boston
i'm not going to get it only if it's
only one of the original 13 columns it's
got to be one of the original 13
colleges
they have to [ __ ] that city have to
prove to me it's a delaware
yeah they fought against [ __ ] tyranny
yeah the george washington role
[Laughter]
okay man that is good stuff let's see
what else we got here
you got anything big man yeah favorite
cartoon when you were a kid
favorite cartoon when i was a kid and
favorite toy favorite
okay so favorite toy was probably my
tatanka action figure
wwf the old school wrestler love him
favorite cartoon
i would say it's a toss-up between
animaniacs and teenage mutant ninja
turtles
classy answers right there wow the
maniacs way ahead of its time
great show i mean that's it's almost
like it's almost like saying your
favorite basketball plays michael jordan
because i know all kids like teenage
mutant ninja turtles
but that's that's what i watched i would
say the most that cartoon
turtles were tight um growing up or now
do you
keep your batteries in the refrigerator
i i don't keep my batteries in the
refrigerator no and i don't think i've
ever
i don't think i've ever done that i've
never done my batteries in the
refrigerator it's all right
okay there you go do you have a amex
card do i have an amex card yes
is it black it's not black it's it's
gray
but it's an amex car it's a delta sky
miles amex card
legit legit legit there you go i have
two credit cards capital one and amex
capital one that's so there you go that
was your first one
that was my first one because i get the
ammo and i only got that one because i i
[ __ ]
jennifer garner i listen to the
commercials
yeah i tell you what she could get me to
do anything anything jennifer garner
showed me that and i i used the points i
used the capital one points because
jg told me to do it jennifer gardner and
catch me if you can
i just watched god oh amazing you know
what's in sleeper pick what i used to
jerk off to all the time when i was a
kid
is uh jamie lee curtis and true lies
buddy jamie lee curtis
places that one i've never seen you've
never seen training places shows her
tits
here's here's some dirtbag [ __ ] about me
she is but that dan when she's dancing
woman in my life never seen any of the
godfathers i've never seen the
godfathers
and i've never eaten a pork chop or had
goat cheese in my whole life
i don't know if that makes me garbage i
don't know [ __ ] is wrong with you that
makes you a wacko
sure yeah well
i don't know you next question but i
never had a pork chop yeah yeah i don't
know we'll find a cup
kind of i don't know i just how do you
not have a pork chop i just i
i honestly might say i don't think i've
ever had a pork chop either i've never
had pork chop
i'm a very weird eater pork chops and
applesauce sauerkraut
yeah no applesauce i've had apple
sausage i used to eat mozza apple sauce
out of the jar with my hands
i didn't get it i was waiting for the
hands i just recently and my go-to
uh kind of yeah well because my daughter
i've eaten it yeah because applesauce
makes a comeback when you have a kid
because you don't forget because now
it's like dipping the macaroni and
cheese and the applesauce is like that's
what we do like i hope that my daughter
doesn't finish her meal even if she's
malnutrition i'm like i wouldn't eat
that [ __ ] applesauce yeah dude
dipping a chicken nugget and [ __ ] oh
sauce ain't nothing wrong i've never
heard
macaroni and cheese enough macaroni and
cheese and chicken nuggets i don't say
by the rules what are you talking about
what it is chrissy chaos and also
saltine crackers and arizona iced tea
that was my snack growing up all the
time
wow yep huh yeah that's a little trashy
yeah it ain't classy it's not classy um
do you get cash back when you're making
a purchase cash back when i'm making a
purchase
meaning like you're at the you're in the
they go do you want cash back and you go
yeah i'll take the check when you hit
the button
you want cash you're at 7-eleven buying
you know
applesauce right and then you want cash
back and i give them a five no no no you
pay with a card i'm sorry okay oh
you're tipping the seven elections no go
ahead that's for you
no no i've never asked i've never asked
for cash back that's
never done that yeah yeah ever use the
atm just to check your balance
um no but i but but just because i have
it on my phone yeah so i
i would use the atm to check my balance
okay
but have you ever stayed at a resort
with a swim up bar
yes multiple ones i mean that's
something that we look forward to doing
you know every year with my friends yeah
yeah ocean city maryland
and where was that where you're going to
vacation
when i was a kid you know when i was a
kid when i was a kid what my mother's
number one we would do we would drive
from new york to florida
that's what what yeah that was a [ __ ]
big one we were always driving a car
oh god probably a toyota yeah toyota no
it's saturn
a saturn that's bad news so we would go
from those things stunk
new york to florida to saturn and then
also my mother would take me on [ __ ]
cruises we would
i would be me and my mom on a cruise
once a year and always be to some
[ __ ] place like i remember one time
she went through a breakup
and she just like on a whim because this
was like the late 90s she was like
i remember she was like going through
this breakup and it was like bad she was
like in a fight on the phone or whatever
and then she's like i'm [ __ ] sick of
this [ __ ] whatever
and then she like wipes off her makeup
and her tears she's like chris she's
like i got great news she's like we're
gonna have a good week and we're gonna
go on a cruise and i'm thinking like
[ __ ] awesome this is great like we're
gonna go to like bermuda or something
like that
nova scotia canada ah with my mom
we could pull up to the dock i'm all
excited i could see these guys are in
[ __ ]
triple gooses triple fat goose jackets
it's july 5th
i'm like what the [ __ ] turn this thing
around hanzo yeah
i had to sit in a singles bar with my
mother for [ __ ] in nova scotia canada
while she was drinking
[ __ ] michelob ultra how old were you
you know 10 11.
whole but i did kiss my first girl on
that ship so it wasn't like really yeah
yeah yeah
it's my first check on that okay you got
flip-flops and a north face on yeah dude
seriously we packed like summer [ __ ]
but she i was like why do we go to nova
scotia she's like that's what the travel
agent said they had available it was
last minute
cruises are pretty trashy pretty trashy
yeah pretty trash holy [ __ ]
uh i think i only got one more here and
i got we got a couple from the patreons
okay okay no please after you sir uh if
you buy a six pack of beer you go home
you put it in the fridge do you take it
out of the case
yes take it out of the case fold it up
put in the recycling okay
[ __ ] class but i put i'll put them in
a drawer i put them in a drawer
i have like a beer drawer but i get that
from my mom because we say on the
historian is hiding the vegetables or
moving the vegetables because my mother
used to hide the beers
that she wanted her sam adams and stuff
underneath the packs of vegetables
because i hated it
she knows i would never go to look for
the vegetables so she was like that's
where i can hide the beer
so i think from that i put the beers in
a in the crisper
yeah right that's where i put them okay
uh you ever used the terms uh instead of
saying thank you you ever say cheers
no i'll never say cheers and it actually
makes me annoyed every time somebody
emails cheers
or [ __ ] text me cheers i'm like this
isn't medieval england [ __ ] face
stop with the cheers you ever call
anybody mate
no i'll never call anybody because
that's the thing is when i'm like you
know you call people mate it's like
i get it but like we were born in
america it's like we were you know what
i mean like we got free from that [ __ ]
why do you think we fought this
revolutionary war for so we could still
be over here say cheers and mate and
cheerio [ __ ] you
wow i know i [ __ ] hate it too i hate
mate and cheers i'm not a fan of mate
and cheers
have you ever said the phrases i wear a
lot of hats or a lot to unpack
no for the hats because i have a size 8
hat head so i
i know i have a good hat so i don't wear
a lot of hats i'm actually the opposite
i will i don't wear hats
a lot to unpack i have a lot to unpack
meaning like
emotionally no have you ever used these
phrases like i got a lot to unpack oh or
something
someone will be like uh now that biden
you know the emotional little
uh baggage of biden being present is a
lot to us
we have a lot to work through a lot to
work with i would instead of saying that
we have a lot to work through
i would say like um yeah you know now
you would say joe biden's present that's
a lot to unpack i would say i demand a
recount
i know that's right yeah yeah seriously
yeah
yeah i would say joe biden's presence is
going to be a long four years
uh have you ever used the term this that
or the other thing like just that the
other thing this that the other thing
um no but i do say yada yada
yeah shout out to seinfeld yeah yeah
yeah give me that um
all right i got a couple do you have any
more then i got a couple from the page
now shoot the patreons all right so guys
as you know when you sign up for the
patreon we will ask one of your garbage
questions it's the only way to do it
because we got so many uh submissions
so this is that these are actually from
uh these are uh
history aina fans oh great you can tell
by the names when they sign up
oh my god their patreon names are
wild this is mike the fuzzy non-muzzy
sandra dj
have you ever donated to npr no i've
never donated to npr and i never will i
don't i don't
he's got the kind of face that he
couldn't even find it on the radio yeah
yeah no no not uh yeah and i've never
listened in my life to npc i mean his
propaganda
he's [ __ ] yeah
uh this is next thing you know i'm using
chopsticks what the [ __ ] you want from
me
oh uh this also this goes into a bigger
one too uh this is victoria make no
mistake doesn't want to get sent
to the back hillier do you ask for more
bread
uh at a restaurant just to steal and
take it home with you
no i've never taken the bread i've never
taken the uh will you do leftovers
i left over 700 take leftovers i have
taken silverware home
oh man that's late in the game he drops
that one okay
he was [ __ ] dude he was chrissy green
lights until that came out why are you
taking silverware
it's just these queens because you
[ __ ] never know when you need a spoon
[Laughter]
i've taken silverware from multiple red
lobsters yeah
speaking of did growing up did you have
milk with dinner milk with dinner
um uh uh uh no never really had milk
with dinner and now i drink mostly
almond milk
wow that's pretty good yeah at your
house is the butter on the counter or in
the refrigerator butter's in the
refrigerator
okay yeah okay people would say that's
classic it's plant-based butter too
she's a she's like a vegan my girl's
like vegan and
really vegetarian so it's plant-based
[ __ ] butter you're creeping that way
no i mean i just got to eat the food she
cooks but it's like i mean as soon as
like i leave here i'm getting a [ __ ]
pepperoni slice
there's a good place on like 30 oh right
on ninth ave 39th and eighth it's really
good
uptown it's called upside pizza or
something like that that's good um how
is the vegan butter
for me it's like butter's butter it's
like it's just it's butter so
i don't taste the difference um but you
know it's just one of those things where
it's like
she because the thing is with her she
didn't tell me like she didn't tell me
she was giving me vegan dishes
like yesterday she cooked uh the
fettuccine alfredo we had the fettuccine
alfredo and then she had crab cakes
but the crab cakes were not real crab
meat it where they were vegan crab cakes
and she didn't tell me until
after it was done i was like those crab
cakes were off awesome i said we're
awesome i was like what'd you go to
maryland and get those she was like
no they're [ __ ] vegan crab cakes she
was like i got them from dr prager so i
was like
damn yeah dr prager is all right they
make a veggie burger it's pretty [ __ ]
pretty [ __ ] good yeah pretty [ __ ]
good
uh all right this is the last one from
patreon this is from kristen this is
a home run of a question does anyone in
your family still have a cd tower a cd
tower
does anyone have my yes my mother still
has a cd tower yeah my mother
my mother still watches things on a dvd
player my mother yeah my mother still
watches
she watched my daughter saw beauty and
the beast for the first time when she
slept at my mother's house last
week and i was like where'd you get
beauty and the beast did you buy it on
tv she's like no i've had the dvd since
you were a little kid
i'm like holy smokes
i just have one last question do you
have an answering machine growing up
when you were a kid
answering machines still to this day the
same answering machines you call my
mother's house it's the same
same answering machine as i had from
when i was a kid is that
is that outgoing message a song that
you're that you and your mom are singing
or your mom is singing is it like a
jokey
type thing or is it just a straight up
or are you involved in the recording
i'm not involved in recording it
something to the if i know if i called
you pick up right now so and then i if i
told her please don't pick up for the
show she'd be like no i
should just keep picking up so it was it
was some it was it's something like
hi hi you've reached i haven't lived
there in 15 years she goes hi you've
reached lynn chris and larry's house
larry's
my mother's dachshund she's like you've
reached lynn chris larry's house
we're not home right now but please
leave a message after the beep and i'll
call you back as soon as i'm done
feeding my dog
yes [ __ ] trash he does well with the
tipping and [ __ ] like that yeah he's
[ __ ] queen's trash nice try pretty
boy yeah
he almost made it out of here bro my
mother still has a rotary phone too
oh [ __ ] yeah she just doesn't like to
party
old school i like it wow okay naming the
dog
in the answering machine major trash the
fact that the dog has a human name
real trash and that and i got to take
all the credit on that my mother said
you can name the dog and i said for me
mom
there's only one option there's only one
option it's got to be a funny human name
so out of those
the only three options that come to mind
larry gary or harry
you pick which one and she picked larry
[Laughter]
i think if you have a pet it has to be a
funny human name like the funniest dog
i've ever seen as i was at the dog run
with my dog larry and there was a
300-pound rottweiler named josephine
some fat chick from queens yeah
oh that's great yeah i mean deal sealed
sealed
the deal with the answer machine you're
[ __ ] trash i love that baby that's
right
we came cl i came close to class real
quick you really you hate the last
questions
it happens how do more people who come
on the show go class garbage is it 50 50
garbage
matter where you came from money this
staff the other thing yeah 99.9
of people are trapped have you had
shultz on yeah
and you gave him garbage nah no garbage
i mean that kid is [ __ ] classy
father's a ballet instructor yeah yeah
yeah but it's like he's like new he
now he's like new money trash a little
bit like he's going to these fancy
restaurants he doesn't know what he's
doing yeah but he does it right yeah
he doesn't but he does it right tim
dillon would be an interesting one
together
timmy is [ __ ] you you don't see the
class coming with that kid no because
you're like oh this is
his kid's a [ __ ] dirtbag from nassau
county and then you talk to him like oh
no timmy is close
he knows his way around a good
restaurant timmy's class and that's one
of the reasons why we can't wait to have
him on is
i want to get some official rulings from
him on
tim actually should yeah he would change
the scope of the show because he may be
able to tell you you're not asking the
right questions you could write the
constitution
yes yeah honestly that's right this
great country yeah
the tim of rights
yeah chrissy d man this is [ __ ]
unbelievable thank you so much for
coming in you got anything you want to
let the folks out there know
um yeah you could find christy
comedy.com i got uh
uh phoenix arizona coming up uh vogel
theater in new jersey
um you know uh i got a podcast hey babe
with salvolcano of course history is
with janice pappas
um you know check us out yeah let's see
i'm beautiful thank you guys time to be
what do you got for him
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available youtube and patreon.com help
us keep the [ __ ] lights on guys thank
you so much for the support what an
episode we love you guys thank you so
much and we will see you next week
peace gang i told you i'll be back to
talk about stereo app didn't i well here
i
am so sit back and listen stereo app
users can engage with the platforms
they can listen in they can seek out
topics they can join conversations and
issues that interest them all right
there's a wide range of conversations
going on on the stereo you got comedy
got pop culture you got lifestyle you
got sports it's absolutely fantastic
and it's also available for iphone and
android users
all right it's something for everybody
okay
and kippy and uncle hank are going to be
doing their first show
january 28th at 9 00 pm we're gonna be
on the stereo app
so go to stereo.com are you garbage
and sign up and get ready january 28th
thursday night 9 pm on the stereo app
are you garbage is going to be going
live and we could not be more excited
thank you